okay I told you that running unopposed
in yesterday's primaries Donald Trump
failed to get eighty percent of the vote
in 45 primaries and there's another
problem for Donald Trump some major
Republican elected officials are coming
out and saying we're not going to be
voting for Donald Trump I'll start with
Illinois Republican Senator Mark Kirk
who said now I'm just not voting for
Donald Trump he said I have spent my
life building bridges and tearing down
barriers not building walls that's why I
find Donald Trump's belief that an
american-born judge of Mexican descent
is incapable of fairly presiding over
his case is not only dead wrong it is
unamerican and then he tweeted the
following about Donald Trump given my
military experience Donald Trump does
not have the temperament to command our
military or our nuclear arsenal then we
go to Republican Nevada Governor Brian
Sandoval very popular mainstream
Republican he says it's not at all clear
that he will be voting for Donald Trump
in November he gave an interview to the
Las Vegas review-journal he was asked
about this he said his vote for Trump is
not for sure Republican senator from
Arizona jeff flake said yesterday as of
now unless he changes significantly I
can't see myself voting for Donald Trump
and Republican governor Charlie Baker
here in Massachusetts said that he will
not back Donald Trump that was back in
March I don't believe that that has
changed since some of these Republicans
will ultimately acquiesce and vote for
Trump in the same way that Paul Ryan has
in spite of still stating that Donald
Trump is saying racist things he's
supporting him many of these Republicans
will ultimately support Trump but when
mainstream Republican senators and
governors are saying either i don't know
that i'm going to support Trump or I
definitely won't this is a unique
situation isn't it it's it's really bad
for Trump uh yeah I guess it's unique
situation um uh I don't know what this
means for the general election but uh we
certainly aren't going to hear them come
out support Hillary Clinton no well
that's the problem right because if you
follow this to its logical conclusion
what do they do in November they're not
going to vote for Hillary they vote for
a third party candidate then they are
going to just help Hillary
and if they don't vote at all just
really doesn't look good unless it's
it's truly a protest vote and they can
couch it in some PR friendly way I you
might just want to say this for your own
benefit I mean yeah uh it's uh that
might be the right move here right to do
further down the road looking at future
elections yeah because well one of the I
forget who it was I have the story for
tomorrow the one congressperson uh
primary candidate endorsed by Trump lost
it is it's really not looking good for
for what's going on down ballot for
Republicans